a continuación tenemos la hoja de
balance del primer banco superior del
lado del activo tiene 200 pesos de
reservas y 1800 pesos de préstamos por
lo que el total de activos es de 2 mil
pesos y eso debería ser lo mismo que sus
pasivos y capital y vemos que aquí tiene
2 mil pesos en depósitos a la vista eso
es una obligación para el banco porque
la gente puede venir al banco y decir
oye quiero mi dinero que representa este
depósito estos son depósitos
verificables por lo que incluso podrían
intentar retirar ese dinero y dado que
esos dos mil pesos están en el lado de
los pasivos no hay capital justo aquí
estos dos deben sumar dos mil pesos la
misma cantidad que tenemos en el lado de
los activos suponga que la proporción de
reserva requerida es el 10% y sólo como
una revisión ese es el porcentaje de
depósitos que el banco necesita mantener
como reservas y podemos ver que está en
ese índice de reservas en este momento
tiene dos mil pesos en depósitos y
necesita mantener 10% como reservas 10%
de 2000 es 200 por lo que ya está en sus
reservas mínimas el inciso a dice cuál
es el valor en pesos de nuevos préstamos
que puede hacer el primer banco superior
expliqué pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo bueno como ya mencioné antes
este banco está al mínimo de sus
reservas ya ha prestado tanto como puede
hacerlo si obtienes dos mil pesos en
depósitos y tienes una proporción de
reservas del 10%
eso significa que puedes prestar el 90
por ciento de esos dos mil y ya has
prestado el 90 por ciento de dos mil
pesos entonces cuál es el valor en pesos
de nuevos préstamos que puede hacer el
primer banco superior bueno es cero
pesos cero pesos porque ya está en las
reservas mínimas
muy bien hagamos el inciso b el señor
pérez deposita 100 pesos en efectivo en
la cuenta de depósitos a la vista del
primer banco superior calcular el valor
máximo de nuevos préstamos que el primer
banco superior puede hacer ahora pausa
en el vídeo nuevamente y traten de
resolverlo hay un par de maneras en que
pueden abordar esto antes de que el
señor pérez hiciera ese depósito vimos
en el inciso a que el primer banco
superior no podía hacer ningún préstamo
nuevo de modo que se obtiene 100 pesos
en efectivo en la cuenta de depósitos a
la vista y la proporción de reservas es
de 10 por ciento puede prestar el otro
90% entonces podemos decir bueno puede
prestar el 90 por ciento de ese nuevo
depósito y eso sería 90% por 100 pesos
lo que es igual a 90 pesos de nuevos
préstamos otra forma de pensar en esto
es
después de que el señor pérez hace el
depósito los depósitos a la vista que
tenemos aquí ascienden a 2100 pesos y
ese incremento en los pasivos se
compensa con un aumento en los activos
simplemente recibió 100 pesos en
efectivo por lo que las reservas van de
200 pesos a 300 pesos ahora en este
punto el primer banco superior está
claramente por encima de sus requisitos
mínimos de reserva 300 / 2100 es más del
10 por ciento por lo que puede prestar
algo de dinero cuánto puede prestar
bueno tiene que mantener el 10% de esos
2100 pesos como reservas por lo que debe
mantener 210 pesos aquí y entonces puede
otorgar 90 pesos en préstamos de modo
que éste puede ser 1890 así que puede
hacer nuevos préstamos por 90 pesos como
resultado del depósito un efectivo de
100 pesos del señor pérez
calcular el cambio máximo en el tiempo
en cada uno de los siguientes incisos
del sistema bancario la primera parte
desde préstamos entonces cuál es el
cambio máximo en el tiempo en el sistema
bancario de préstamos pausa en el vídeo
y traten de resolverlo
bueno como hemos dicho por el depósito
que hizo el señor pérez por 100 pesos el
primer banco superior puede hacer nuevos
préstamos por 90 pesos pero a quien sea
que le haya hecho ese préstamo podría
depositar ese dinero en un banco y
entonces el banco podría prestar 90 por
ciento de eso entonces sería más 0.9 por
90 ahora este banco que obtuvo 0.9 por
90 pesos que es igual a 81 pesos ahora
puede prestar el 90 por ciento de eso
entonces va a ser más 0.9 por esto que
es igual a 0.9 al cuadrado por 90 y
podemos continuar así y de esto
obtenemos esencialmente la ecuación para
el multiplicador que puede ser que la
hayan memorizado esto es igual a 90 por
1 sobre 1 - podríamos decir 0.9 o
podríamos decir que esto
lo mismo que noventa por uno sobre la
proporción de reservas que es 0.1
y uno sobre 0.1 es igual a 10 así que
esto es igual a 900 pesos ahora cuál
sería el cambio máximo en el tiempo en
depósitos a la vista pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo cuando el señor
pérez depósito 100 pesos en efectivo en
el primer banco superior eso incrementó
los depósitos a la vista en 100 pesos en
la hoja de balance del primer banco
superior dejen de escribirlo de esta
manera tenemos 100 pero también dijimos
que el primer banco superior podría
prestar el 90 por ciento de eso y a
quien fuera que lo hubiera prestado lo
podría depositar en un banco como un
depósito a la vista lo que es igual a
más 0.9 por 100 y luego ese banco podría
prestar lo 0.9 por esto y luego quien
obtuviera ese préstamo podría
depositarlo en un banco creando un
depósito a la vista
entonces 0.9 al cuadrado
por cien y así podríamos continuar y
podríamos ver esto como esto es igual a
cien por uno sobre uno menos 0.9 que es
lo mismo que 100 por uno sobre el
porcentaje de reserva entonces esto es
igual a 100 por 10 lo que es igual a mil
pesos
inciso d como resultado del depósito en
efectivo de 100 pesos del señor pérez
calcular el cambio máximo en el tiempo
de la oferta monetaria pausa en el vídeo
nuevamente y traten de pensar en esto
tal vez te sientas tentado a decir oye
tal vez es lo mismo que el cambio máximo
total en los depósitos a la vista pero
debemos ser muy cuidadosos estos 100
pesos ya existían como efectivo en la
oferta monetaria el cambio máximo es
todo lo demás es esta parte que tenemos
aquí el señor pérez depósito 100 pesos
en efectivo que no era dinero nuevo pero
luego el banco podría prestar el 90 por
ciento de eso que son 90 pesos de dinero
nuevo que alguien podría usar para
depositarlo en otro banco y luego ese
otro banco podría prestar el 90 por
ciento de esos 90 y hemos visto este
ejercicio antes ese fue exactamente el
mismo cálculo para la primera parte aquí
esto va a ser igual a 90 por 1 sobre el
porcentaje de reservas
es igual a 900 pesos
inciso y proporcionar una razón por la
cual el cambio real en la oferta
monetaria puede ser más pequeño que el
cambio máximo que se identificó en el
inciso de pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo bueno en realidad hay dos
buenas razones por las que el cambio
real en la oferta monetaria podría ser
menor que lo que acabamos de calcular
una razón es que los bancos decidieran
retener más que las reservas mínimas
entonces los bancos podrían retener más
que las reservas mínimas
así que podríamos imaginar que aunque
según la ley de acuerdo con este
escenario tienen que mantener un
porcentaje de reservas del 10% siempre
medio los bancos deciden mantener un
porcentaje de reserva del 20% cada vez
que otorgarán el 80 por ciento de lo que
sea que obtengan por depósitos tendrá un
número menor aquí hay otro escenario en
el que la gente que obtiene los
préstamos no los deposita en el sistema
bancario entonces si queremos una
segunda razón ya hemos contestado la
pregunta ya dijimos una razón pero una
segunda razón es que la gente no
deposite todos sus fondos en el sistema
bancario hasta el próximo vídeo